l'armée vietnamienne annoncé aujourd'hui
qu'elle venait de réussir une opération
décisive au cambodge en prenant le
quartier général des khmers rouges
installés à phnom malaye cet événement
justifie que nous consacrions ce soir un
long dossier au cambodge
car dix ans après le martyre qu'a connue
ce pays lors de sa conquête par les
khmers rouges
des dizaines de milliers de civils
fuient encore aujourd'hui ils fuient
cette fois devant la vietnamien qui
depuis la fin de l'année dernière ont
lancé une offensive sans précédent
contre les régions du cambodge qui leur
résistent encore ces charniers
découverts par l'armée vietnamienne
après la chute de phnom penh une
justification avancée par hanoï à son
intervention au cambodge
la terreur du régime de pol pot est le
génocide perpétré par les khmers rouges
ont permis au voisin vietnamien
d'envahir le cambodge en 79
ces soldes apparaissait alors comme des
libérateurs
en fait il s'agissait plutôt d'occuper
le cambodge
les vietnamiens myrte en place un régime
cambodgien leur sol dirigé par karim est
depuis six ans ils se sont implantés
dans tout le pays plus de cent mille
soldats
le plus gros des troupes sur la
frontière ouest car depuis six ans ils
ont à faire face à une guérilla
cambodgienne de plus en plus organisés
au départ les maquisards que mer rouge
aujourd'hui tout un front de résistance
politiquement diversifiée située le long
de la frontière avec la thaïlande empile
symbole de la résistance non communiste
tombé le mois dernier c'était le
quartier général des sagnes un
nationaliste mer dix mille hommes appuyé
politiquement par les états unis
les khmers rouges pro chinois les plus
anciens maquisards entre vingt et trente
mille hommes armés par pékin fer de
lance de la résistance et cyanokit 6000
hommes un mouvement qui vise surtout à
travers la stature du prince yens
ces trois mouvements se sont coalisés
encan putsch ère démocratique
c'est lui qui occupe le siège du
cambodge nations unies
cette coalition s'est fait sous la
pression de la chine parties prenantes
au conflit
pour d'évidentes raisons géostratégiques
outre paix du champ de bataille la
thaïlande frontalière sur le pied de
guerre depuis 79 base arrière des
maquisards
elle sert aussi de transit pour le
matériel militaire chinois destinés à la
résistance
assailli par les vietnamiens s'emparer
de la dernière des grandes bases de la
résistance khmers qui étaient installés
dans l'ouest du cambodge est tout près
de la frontière thaïlandaise
comme l'expliquent ces officiers
thaïlandais plus de 30000 soldats
appuyés par une vingtaine de chars
lourds ont participé à l'attaqué du
quartier général des khmers rouges à
phnom my face à l'offensive des soldats
de hanoi
la plupart des 10000 maquisards qui
tenait jusqu'à présent ce massif
montagneux se sont dispersés dans la
jungle pour ensuite pouvoir harceler les
convois vietnamienne cela signifie non
seulement que les troupes vietnamiennes
pourrait avoir du mal à tenir toutes les
positions qu'elles ont conquise depuis
le début de leur offensive en novembre
dernier mais aussi que leur victoire
d'aujourd'hui ne signifie pas pour
autant la fin de la résistance mer en
revanche la prise de phnom malaye
permettent à l'armée vietnamienne de
priver ses adversaires d'une source
importante d'approvisionnement en armes
et en munitions qui jusqu'à présent été
livrés dans cette zone par la chine
populaire
quant aux deux autres composantes de la
résistance cambodgienne leur situation
n'est guère brillante toutes les bases
des maquisards non communistes du
ministre sonne ça ne sont occupées par
les vietnamiens depuis le début de
l'année et le principe à nuuk et ses
partisans ne dispose plus que du camp de
tatum dans le nord du pays
en attendant l'offensive vietnamienne de
ces derniers jours a provoqué la fuite
de 48 nouveaux réfugiés en territoire
thaïlandais aujourd'hui près de deux
cent mille réfugiés cambodgiens
s'entassent dans ces camps thaïlandais
la première vague est arrivée là en 75
après la chute de phnom penh la deuxième
vague les a rejoints en 79 lorsque les
troupes vietnamiennes sont entrés au
cambodge 26 ans fait partie de ceux là
il est d'abord resté dans son pays en se
cachant
et puis un jour il a décidé de partir et
comment s'est passée cette fuite
moi c'était un ami
et s'acquitter abattement traversée dans
les dents pendant deux semaines
malheureusement il ya deux de camara ils
sont pas les crocs parce que c'était
tombé dans l'embuscade
si vous êtes passés dans des zones
dangereuses oui il y en a sont nominés
qui plante et la faune qui y étaient
dans les rues thaïlandaises et vous êtes
arrivée en thaïlande
oui vous avez été dans un camp de
réfugiés oui et alors là c'était comment
c'est accueilli par les croix rouge
internationale et comment vous en êtes
arrivé a décidé de partir se pensent ce
ne peut pas vivre sous le régime
communiste
il n'ya pas liberté ce goût très la
liberté sauvage et pour tous et
cambodgiens déchiré d'avoir dû quitter
leurs terres à laquelle ils sont par
nature très attaché
la vraie liberté c'est le départ des
troupes vietnamiennes du cambodge
d'accord enfin l'essai refusé il
s'enfuit en fin de mon pays
ils sont qui sont très misérables ils
ont ils ont beaucoup souffert
l'occident est généreux les nations
unies tout le monde se mobilise pour
apporter des aides mais ce n'est qu'une
solution provisoire
c'est une solution trop souvent parce
que le malade
enfin si si souvenez en exemple de
malades
le malade est gravement malade il s'agit
pas d'appliquer en cataplasme parce
qu'il faudrait ils ont mené une
opération chirurgicale et de grande
envergure et la religion sur les jca
c'est la solution politique c'est la
solution préconisée par les nations
unies qui demandent le retrait total des
troupes d'occupation vietnamienne et non
le droit à l'autodétermination du peuple
cambodgien pour l'instant aucun indice
ne laisse à penser que les chinois vont
intervenir comme en 1979
par contre il ya eu des déclarations du
ministre chinois des affaires étrangères
qui peuvent effectivement laisser à
penser qu'on ira dans cette direction
mais aucun mouvement de troupe sur la
frontière n'est intervenu en direction
du vietnam
qu'est ce qui change est maintenant dans
cette partie du monde avec l'attak
vitamines contre le camp de phnom à
l'ail
le premier aspect c'est la crédibilité
maintenant diplomatique du gouvernement
quand putsch et démocratique
il est vrai qu'en perdant ces zones
libérées à l'intérieur du cambodge
la position diplomatique du gouvernent
du gouvernement du prince sihanouk va
être extrêmement délicate
on pourra voir dans les prochains mois
comment les pays de la région comment
les pays occidentaux comment lurs
comment les états unis vont réagir à
l'égard de cette nouvelle situation
la résistance n'a plus de base politique
maintenant votre avis sebah se sont
énormément affaibli en raison de ses
pertes militaires les grandes puissances
je pense notamment aux états unis a lui
aussi bien revenue à la chine telles
qu'elles peuvent faire il faut savoir ce
que vont décider les vietnamiens si les
vietnamiens sont décidés à rentrer dans
un jeu de négociation effectivement
l'union soviétique aura son mot à dire
notamment après la visite les derniers
contacts entre la chine la chine et
l'union soviétique
la chine est directement impliqué dans
ce dans ce conflit les états unis aussi
on a trop souvent oubliée au cours de
ces derniers mois les états unis lui
manifestement il se passe quelque chose
entre les états unis et le vietnam